Rund
1900 vulkane gibt es wohl auf der erde und da sind die in den ozean noch nicht mehr mitgezählt
mindestens genau so viele gibt es alleine auf dem planeten venus und
viele weitere auch auf unseren anderen nachbar planeten was wissen wir über die vulkane auf anderen planeten und inwieweit geben sie hinweise auf
außerirdisches leben herzlich willkommen bei pixum science fiction und
Vielen dank für den themenvorschlag auf whatsapp und in anna messengern wirklich ein sehr spannendes thema nämlich 120
kilometer hoch war die rauchfahne später es stand genau an dieser stelle ein dunkler fleck mit einem durchmesser von sage und schreibe
400 kilometern die rede ist von einem vulkanausbruch auf dem jupitermond io der gigantische landstriche
verändert hat ist wohl einer der vulkanisch aktivsten die stirn im sonnensystem die amerikanische raumsonde galileo hatte im jahr
2000 diese bilder möglich gemacht aber dieser ausbruch war nur einer von vielen auf dem mond des jupiters schon seit
1979 hatte die raumsonde voyager1 aufnahmen gemacht die beweisen dass ihr vulkanisch aktiv ist hervorgerufen durch gezeitenkräfte
die der große jupiter auf seinen kleinen trabanten auswirkt diese heizen ihm auf und kneten ihn gnadenlos durch vulkanausbrüche
auf anderen planeten unseres weltalls sind tatsächlich nicht mit denen auf unserer erde zu vergleichen lavafontänen
steigen bei uns maximal einen kilometer in den himmel hinauf auf
dagegen ist die schwerkraft kleiner und auch die fehlende atmosphäre
trägt dazu bei dass die lava fetzen sehr viel höher kommen die
vulkane
spucken die brodelnde masse weit ins all hinaus zudem handelt es sich bei canis muss auf anderen planeten nicht immer nur um lava vulkane
sondern es gibt auch andere arten wie eisvulkane beispielsweise forschungsteams weltweit begannen mit ihren untersuchungen
zu wirken im all etwa ab den 70er jahren als das apollo team
vulkanische steine mit von seiner expedition brach der mars hat wohl den gigantischen schild vulkan im gesamten sonnensystem mehr als
20 kilometer ist olympus mons in die höhe
erreicht er sein durchmesser erreicht an die 600 kilometer
schild vulkan entstehen wenn sich mehrere
lavaströme übereinander lagern nach schätzungen ist der gigantisch zum vulkan in die menschheit kennt wohl vor etwa einer milliarde jahren entstanden und hatte vor
220 millionen jahren die letzte eruption weil der mas kleiner ist als die erde beträgt die kavitation hier auch nur etwa ein drittel
so stieg die man das manchmal wohl schneller auf und zwar es leichter und schneller weiter er gehört zu einer ganzen vulkan
provinz auf dem mars die etwa so groß ist wie ganz europa ist im vergangenen sommer hatte ein forschungsteam aus tschechien an gebiet mit weiteren
130 kleinen vulkan entdeckt und zwar mit der hilfe der nasa raumsonde mars reconnaissance orbiter
eine besonders große überraschung war dabei das alter der vulkane von gerade einmal
200 bis 400 millionen jahren zudem fanden sie mit einem spektrometer tatsächlich hinweise darauf dass dort auch einmal
außerirdisches leben existiert haben könnte konkret fanden sie mineral mit viel silizium
teilweise waren auch opal artige substanzen fahren diese zusammensetzung
deutet darauf hin dass mineral aus heißen lösungen ausgefallen und mineralisiert wurden also eine warme
mineralreiche und energie spendende umgebung perfekt also als lebensraum für mikroorganismen
die gegen soll jetzt noch weiter auf 1 vorhandenes leben auf dem mars untersucht werden auf der venus dagegen ist der so genannte
hot spot vulkanismus zu finden also gebiete mit einer aktiven großen unterirdischen magma kammer
2015 sein forschungsteam der esa überzeugende hinweise darauf dass die venus auch heute noch vulkanisch aktiv ist
eine heiße und dichte wolke schicht hatte das bis dahin verborgen gehalten doch der infrarotdetektoren der esa raumsonde venus express
konnte mehrere hotspots aufspüren die eine auffallend erhöhte temperatur aufweisen
und zwar in bereits bekannten vulkan regionen auf der venus die vermutung der wissenschaftler und wissenschaftlerinnen
frische aber bereits erstarrte lavaströme
außerdem konnten schwankende schwefeldioxid werte in der atmosphäre entdeckt werden auch das lässt auf aktiv vulkanismus schließen dazu
hakans wtm einer der beteiligten esa forscher
unsere studie zeigt dass die venus unser nächster nachbar noch heute aktiv ist und sich
verändert das ist ein wichtiger schritt auf unsere erforschung der geschichte dieses und unseres planeten
allerdings werden hier offene lavaflüsse vermittelt und keine ausbrüche
wie bei uns auf der erde die lager soll demnach leicht und flüssig aus der venus oberfläche
heraustreten und dann windet wieder unter die küste zurück strömen wie bei uns ganz einfache flüsse bis zu mehreren hundert kilometern
sollen die lavaströme
dort lang sein wenn er kein video dazu und zu allen anderen themen verpassen wollen dann endet mich
darum geht ihr die etwas
unzuverlässiger cobox sie auf youtube
und ihr verpasst kein video denn über whatsapp erfahrt ihr von mir persönlich von jedem upload und zwar noch vor allen anderen
täglich
garantiert einfach drauf kriegen und am besten auch mein schwesterkanal klicks um social media abonnieren
da gibt es das neueste aus der social media welt dafür hier klicken da klicken dann klicken aber nicht die
genau die leute vergessen hier geht es weiter mit dafür auch draufklicken
supervulkan wird ausbrechen bis dann